in the Wasteland that scars the center
of the city
a rescue team begins to probe a great
pile of debris
their scoop is effective no one's
checked this place before
but there's too much to do in caravan
Mirage
if you hear me tap on the wall
no no one
in a city where tens of thousands sleep
outside the authorities need to clear
the rubble but there is a conflicting
demand to search for survivors
at the elbra apartment block a
multinational rescue team had located a
woman called Layla deep beneath the pile
and they'd been working all night to
release her
[Music]
[Applause]
they just called for silence
uh there we go there's another one the
last time they did this
they could hear her they could hear this
woman Layla
okay they've been told to go back to
work and
and they do seem to be picking up the
pace now
they had little Choice the temperature
was dropping an Italian volunteer told
us they were running out of time we
start to call her to us yeah she
answered to us and uh she give a sugar
but the voice was very far and uh not
very strong because you know after four
days
she will be weak yeah very weak
the word had spread about another
emergency
just around the corner a man had been
located in the remains of an 11-story
block
and we found a small group standing
under the teeth of a Digger's bucket
the driver heard a sound in the rubble
and decided to stop his machine
[Applause]
a man called ger Khan emerged from the
rubble his feet were blistered and his
face was lacerated but he had managed to
survive more than four days Underground
[Music]
God is great shouted the crowd
some said they'd seen a miracle
[Music]
the diggers returned to their concrete
heaps
while the rescue team at the elbra Block
looked for Layla
but they told us there'd been a
development
Layla's voice may have belonged to her
son the pair lying together in the boy's
room
we are walking really really hard to get
to the point the team got to a point
where they are on the other side of the
wall but with between them there is a
wall that they can't cut because it's
part of the structure and a washing
machine you can't cut through the
washing machine you can't cut through
the beam so they currently know where he
is but yet it's gonna take a lot of time
the operation was dangerous the tunnel
at risk of collapse
but the team managed to reach the boy
his name is ridvan
Layla's nine-year-old son
the volunteers called for quiet for fear
of alarming the boy
and ridvan was greeted to the sound of
Whispers
he'd spent nearly five days underground
in the arms of his mother
and he was cold and badly dehydrated
the paramedics sped him to hospital
we spoke to rid Van's uncle
the rescue took 24 hours and ridwan is
now in a stable condition
unfortunately his mother Layla had died
holding her son until the end
a national catastrophe and a family's
tragedy in a city marked by sorrow
John Sparks Sky News in caravan Mirage